- So wait, we both grew
up during the '80s,
so what were your favorite
parts of the decade?
Did you love the music?
- Man, I loved the music, man.
We used to have a show
that came on Friday night
in Indiana called "Night Trax"
and they played all '80s.
- [Kelly] With an X?
- A "Night Trax"
- [Kelly] Trax, with an X?
- Yeah, with the X.
- [Kelly] They were cool.
- Yeah, yeah and man, they
played Bruce Springsteen.
- They played...What's her name?
Grace Jones.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Yeah, I got introduced to
a lot of music from the '80s
that, you know, it's like-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- '80s music was the best.
- I feel like too,
like radio was more broad.
Like you could hear like
so many different kinds
of artists on one station.
- [Mike] Yeah.
- Yeah, I like that.
- British music.
- [Kelly] I love...What?
- That's why people like
lot of my black friends
they like, man, how you
know all this white music?
- "Night Trax"
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- "Night Trax" with an X.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They knew what was up.
♪ It's the Rhinestone Cowboy ♪
Yeah exactly.
(Kelly laughs)
♪ I was living on a ♪
See, you just need-
- They didn't know I knew that.
- I know, but you know that,
and Grace Jones and Bruce Springsteen
they're all on the same chain.
That's amazing.
- And, I know Pooh Shiesty.
Do you ever heard of Pooh Shiesty?
- No, Pooh Shiesty?
(Mike laughs)
That sounds like something else.
- It's a rapper, it's a rapper.
(Mike laughs)
- Sounds like something else.
Maybe, it's a different
name where you grow up.
I don't know.
(Kelly laughs)
It's a family show,
sorry, I took it there.